[Music]  so kate is helping you with an avengers  level threat  he's my partner  it's kind of a stretch this thanksgiving  comes the six-part marvel event you  can't miss  you want to be a superhero you put your  life in danger there's also the cool  costumes some trick arrows some people  have actually called me the world's  greatest archer are you one of those  people  marvel studios hawkeye streaming  november 24th only on disney plus  can i tell you a secret  i'm working with an avenger  [Music]  can i speak to your manager  [Music]  didn't realize you're still spring guns  [Music]  it's almost christmas  i can't go home  until i fix this  should we be worried i'll be home for  christmas  i promise  [Applause]  sorry shannon  we're the regular arrows  oh my god trick arrows  we're saving the holidays  marvel studios hawkeye first two  episodes streaming november 24th only on  disney plus  you